لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
في بدايه الامر الدولار ارتفع على خلفيات
التصريحات المتشدده ولكن بعض ذلك تراجع
الدولار الامريكي البعض يقول يعني عده
اسباب وتفسيرات لذلك اولا اذا نظرنا الى
الفاتي هذه توقعات الاصوات بشان نسبه
الفائده الاقصى السنه القادمه هذه
التوقعات حاليا تقف عند اربع فاصل 9% كذرو
وتنفائده السنه القادمه هذا اقل من النسبه
الصادره من الفيدرالي نفسه التي تقع عند
5.1% هذه النسبه 5.1 اعلي من تقديرات
الفتى السابقه وبالتالي اعلى من تقديرات
السوق هذا يعني انه الاصوات غير مقتنعه
بعد انه يستطيع الوصول بالفائده الى ال
5.1% التي يتنبا بها
[موسيقى]
السوق يعني متفائل اكثر من الواقع
الاسهم واذا شفت السوق
اقرب الى الواقع انا اعتقد انه الفدرالي
من عده اشهر
يعني الرساله اللي قاعد يرسلها جدا واضحه
لكن السوق مو قاعد يسمع الرساله هذه
[موسيقى]